like a playing a pro-wrestler like what
the [ __ ] I would never do that if
someone's like yeah they thought you'd
be interested playing a pro be like oh
that's kind of interesting let me read
the [ __ ] thing maybe I was a [ __ ] for
it or whatever is I'm never yeah
something I would never even think of
myself to our being in the Bryan Callen
biopic you know biopic but yeah don't
say biopic right because that's [ __ ]
annoying as [ __ ] but you know what I
mean right
that's awesome if they made a biopic of
you who would play you I mean you'd have
to have somebody Moranis right what did
you say
no I'm asking you if you saw Honey I
Shrunk the Kids you've seen that right
Moran you think Rick Moranis would play
me well at him up at his age now right
he's retired now not that that it's
young right this one there you go I mean
well your little yeah you got it there
couple things
your little rounder in the gotta take it
back now if he was gonna do your biopic
take it back no idea you don't want it
you know wanna [ __ ] spindly legs do
we forget how spindly my legs are did
you forget do it okay right
just out of reach right ah Rick Moranis
would play you did on your biopic see
that's how you get out of a fight you
exhaust the guy I'm spindly hood like
like didn't work so yes so that's who
would play you in it's fine I think it's
good yeah thanks man
yeah no problem let's do some current
events I'm already we don't have a bit
called dropping knowledge don't mock
love a bit about how you want to save a
girl from [ __ ] the guys from taken
yeah well don't have a bit called drop
don't pause when you say it just say
dropping mountains alright
I ate raw elk this morning or almost
Romeoville I have a light energy can be
a lot of videos that libros dude a lot
of it you take terrible videos don't say
anything
the water your restaurant I usually
never hated oh my god I'm like I gotta
jump into my racing after you guys told
me that dude come on
well kiss my it's bit beyond Coney it's
my boys wrestling I'm sure the
restaurants great amazing but take a
better video that's right he's so low I
read an Aurora I realize that the video
love Sara might literally like and you
know it take out the lot of music yeah
and then it's not good then y'all me and
Frank delicious spaghetti it's a god
dude when you said that when I get a
text it just said hey this video makes
me really want to go to this restaurant
you go sure does I was like I got
self-conscious immediately it was late
though I know what you're trying to do
right but I watched and I was like well
this is the worst video this is a
literally the lowest budget I would
never go to that restaurant now the
window is shot that's the way it was
shot the way what whatever video you put
up there it literally look like the only
person that thought it would be good is
David Lynch that's what that video look
like oh my god
a dead corpse in the corner with flies
on it and I never explained why and and
I want to just put something to rest
here there has been when I do a lot of
stand-up you know I've been doing a long
time sure and there's this there's this
whole [ __ ] thing where people go they
see you and they this kid reminds us
okay a Bryan Callen before he became you
know what did the master that he is and
it's funny because I know I've been a
huge influence on you know open we used
to feature know and so I've been a big
big Lou just my physicality and then
here you are here you come kind of
bending around and no no I don't think
so so so I want to say that you have
found your own like the other day I
watched your stand-up and being
condescended here it stays for the first
time ok here actually you actually
sprouted wings you actually grown all
your feathers he's done ready to release
you from the bowl do not say it does not
say they want anybody else to say that
you are like you are my product ok
nobody's saying that one
four more to get out of that shot no
it's like Steve Young no you know you've
grown your full set of mature wings get
out there and fly here's the deal be
scared you say that yeah and then you
suck him into it as well and he's like
oh yeah you're saying about the and
don't have the quarterback comparison
thing it's not like that what do you
mean what I'm saying is I never knew who
you were
what Wow until years after I started
stand-up you playing in coffee shop oh
and what is eclipse to you okay and
that's okay what you don't see it's okay
but people started to be like who's that
guy on Krista Leah's Instagram sometime
you know what can I do another football
reference okay
he's drew bledsoe you're Tom Brady it is
like that yeah is it more like it's not
like it just because you're making your
voice lower I hope you could I'm being
I'm getting serious now
no you're not getting Arrius listen up
okay what's up fly oh no I know what
you're saying that but I don't like one
of your best but dude can I tell you
guys something
honestly I this is the craziest thing
but for months now I've been driving
around and like the other day like I
would drive I'll be war I was I'm gonna
the street the other day and some guy
drives by and he says why and I'm like
what and he's driving right just drives
by sunset I yeah yeah it says on Sunset
Boulevard and I get a coffee I get I get
a coffee at the coffee bean the other
day and the guys like won't you want me
to put down your name for the drink and
he says or should I just put it under
why and I was like what
okay he's like not just kidding Chris
and I was like okay sure and then so
he's like no it's not this is [ __ ]
hilarious a weird interesting story so I
was at a meeting the other day and I sit
down and the guy goes hey Chris why and
but he looked at me and and and I and I
was like I don't understand what you're
saying he was like never mind anyway you
know I've been going to therapy a lot
right so I am I therapist I'm telling
her this
I'm telling that the water I don't
understand what people are saying why
it's got me to joke about putting why in
the coffee cup and she says and she says
mmm and this is what we came to work
here no I don't know I know I know
she said maybe they're wondering why you
were would do the fighter in the kid
[Applause]
yeah she said I said because it doesn't
help your career
and and and and and and I and over ten
million downloads yeah Fred you picked
this trainer Maz Jobrani [ __ ] I don't
I actually don't know how but he was
telling me about how he was to do it and
he was great and I was like oh maybe
I'll see what it's all about
and then I just he came over and I just
like with you how many times a week four
oh damn yeah dude they're getting
stronger my pants fit differently now
because my ass is higher Wow it's a
little higher he's working that booty
yeah yeah well congratulations on things
surprised you got a trainer yeah has
your skin do you think is your skin ever
seen the Sun like dude the question I
don't want it to look like leather when
I get your age that's not cool
yeah well you do glow no I don't do blow
would you do I'll be honest when I first
met Chris everybody's made every drug in
the book everyone I got like can I get
six actually never even smoked why no no
drinks nothing yeah you don't even drink
you know [ __ ] hey what the [ __ ] have
you ever had alcohol in your mouth now
what a [ __ ] you're taking you're a
goody-goody Tim out of hand this College
specials the Comedy Store compared to
other places now like just the how why I
don't know any did before I don't know
anything dude sometimes it would be and
now it's it's the hottest place in
lausanne Rogan says it's like the 80s or
the main travel yeah there's a
Renaissance going on dude I am
everywhere I mean no you're not man it
you know but that's what they say
whoo-hoo whether they say be know the
comedy store press release always like
there's what these press release know
but there's the lion and then there's
all the rest of these day like pound for
pound and your
yeah the Lion of comedy you don't hear
that
no yay you know any of that don't know
you're not gonna make my I've heard a
little chatter you know what you know
I've heard a little about discounts or
press release dude I tell you they are
saying they are saying though they are
like and I fir they're like dude they're
like a dick now no I'm not I'm not
trying to be a dick I swear to god this
is the JIT [ __ ] okay
apparently when I go to the Comedy Store
people are it's very [ __ ] weird I
didn't get it for a long time but
they're handing me like footballs and
[ __ ] what is that why why I don't I
don't play sports or [ __ ] like that
weeks would go by and they'd be like
they wanted you to sign them I was like
doing me signs they were like you go
champ and I was like okay I don't want
the [ __ ] I don't get it I thought it was
a joke that somebody said on a pirate or
whatever dude they're calling me the
quarterback of the comedy [ __ ] am I
getting all these footballs its mouth
Gordon women we're like now so I'll say
that because they're calling me Simba no
Wow let's start this and in all
seriousness with saying something nice
about each other I'm cutting there's a
lot of negativity in the world and I
just feel like [ __ ] you that really
didn't last long man that's not good
well I do like the vibe right I'm sorry
we're gonna start saying well he's put
on his shades oh praise you know why
that makes me upset I know I you know
what like we deposit it and we are and I
don't like putting my shades on yeah but
my future is too bright all right man
well mine you're making it hard to say
something nice please please please
don't please be charitable with us as
well when we're agree okay there's a
reason why Shum and I have sunglasses I
mean you don't have yours on you know
you do you put some guys on the back
your head you're that guy okay look at
its past
guys listen up listen up I'm trying to
be really popular okay and I and so I'll
start by rising above your insults
because you're barred and sits now I'm
not sold and it's okay well I didn't
tell you though because you guys are
young so it's fine first of all you're
young so that's it we are
a lot of guys are you guys are doing
well and you're up-and-coming now all
right well you're not I don't say Chris
you're almost you're gonna be 40 soon
and well so it had that's when I have
seen that happen in a movie way for you
really or have two movies coming out
this year you know what I mean no one
coming out a week thank you it was on
that big what has happened yeah and
things didn't you know they didn't he
wasn't able to carry the show through
right then that's okay because very few
people can do that here's what's good
about you is that you work social media
really well audience you have a young
audience I feel like you're being mean
kind no no I'm Bambi look at this just
in
this just in dude yeah this just in on
deadlines Chris D'Elia to star in
psychopath comedy series and works at
YouTube Brett what's that and it's going
on there no that's great and it's what's
going on there today it came out what
the [ __ ] like eight years ago
do you ever when I see this picture I I
say you lead singer Nickelback
yeah I buy it basically you played a
nickel dog well let me sing why did you
why'd you hold on why did you take a
photo shoot like this though I didn't
mean to first of all Congrats it's thank
you cool psychopath comedy series yeah
Russell Brand is that you can you bring
this up it's on ok can we stand point
you look like Russell Brand and I think
that I don't really look you have his um
you have his energy can I take care of a
some that's a that your hair style here
huh no have an eagle on his shirt or an
owl
an owl so you girls are more gangster
than owl so you kind of one-up Drake huh
I like that but chin bring up the
brilliant Chris's sweatshirt eagle
sweatshirt I want to just I want to look
at this because I think you need work on
the bird I feel like it's apparent well
you're [ __ ] wrong spell my name right
but I know I know I know I know I know
listen I don't worry about that how has
it been going Chris the whole murder
good it's down there the black one yeah
dude let me explain something Oh see the
back go back
that's not even me go down the middle
don't talk about just by the promise
that looks a lot like a macaw it
literally does look like a parrot ya
think
no here's why your son saying that
parent here's why you're saying that
it's not why is it's it's still which is
the point and it's not like this joke
that's the [ __ ] joke you pieces big
deal Eagle dressed as a parent is that
fair no it's not fair but it's literally
nothing like a parrot and that's final
notify yeah Eagle that's what happens to
the Eagles have much bigger beaks buddy
they're a lot bigger I think they're
bigger they grow you're actually I've
seen a bald eagle sir yes wrong that you
be a bald eagle first chin also what the
[ __ ] who are those people I'm taking
pictures with those be your fans parent
but what okay that's got hat flowers on
a little bit look here I'm not mad
that's your dick though you can see your
dick pulled you got a you got a dick in
that pic Christie's got a dick I've seen
yeah Chris show oh no we've seen the
dick when he's doing the yeah Chris
Chris it's I just pulled his dick out
when it was kind of half hard we're
doing the podcast and he goes there you
go and I go what the [ __ ] I don't even
know all right well what if I go almost
figured all that out to lunch today bro
you think I give a [ __ ] bro I'm gonna
faint sitting down have you ever done
that what have you what did you do last
night that you would finish it like
Shawn granite do you've seat you up in
the night every night he it's like a
stack of pancakes all this off penis
Bala see dude I [ __ ] eat real good
like what chocolate chip pancakes no man
I even [ __ ] protein ding ding yeah
are you protein ping ping and I [ __ ]
you know I make sure I eat the leafy
greens and I thought the pilot and your
neck is jutting your heads jutting it
forward your ear isn't in line with your
shoulder you look tired
yeah I'm tired as [ __ ] why mandatory it
any breakfast I gotta eat after this hey
what kind of [ __ ] cool hot spot do
you want to go dude how about Brian when
he [ __ ] post an Instagram video of
him and his friends in a dark when I see
that [ __ ] I'm alone and I go like this
god [ __ ] did you die right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]